موسكو لا تعارض تجديد اتفاق البحر الاسود
الذي يسمح بالتصدير الامن للحبوب من موانئ
اوكرانيا لكن لمده 60 يوما فقط وهي نصف
فتره التمديد السابقه اتفاقيه مبادره حبوب
البحر الاسود تنص على التنديد لمده 120
يوما على الاقل وبالتالي فان موقف روسيا
بتمديدها لمده 60 يوما فقط يتعارض مع
الوثيقه التي وقعتها تركيا والامم المتحده
بعد ساعات قليله ردت الامم المتحده مؤكده
التزامها باتفاق الحبوب في البحر الاسود
قائله ان مديرها العام سيبذل قصار جهده
للحفاظ على سلامته اما اوكرانيا فقد
انتقدت قرار روسيا خفض فتره التمديد لا
يعارض الجانب الروسي تمديدا اضافيا
لاتفاقيه البحر الاسود بعد انتهاء فترتها
الثانيه في الثامن عشر من مارس اذار ولكن
لمده 60 يوما فقط
في الثاني والعشرين من يوليو الماضي بعد
خمسه اشهر من بدء الصراع توصلت كيوب
وموسكو الى اتفاق بشان تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه بعدما تسبب الغزو الروسي في
توقف التصدير لفتره نصت الاتفاقيه التي
وقعت برعايه الامم المتحده وتركيا على
السماح بتصدير الحبوب بامان من ثلاثه
موانئ اوكرانيه وتم تجديدها في نوفمبر
الماضي لمده 120 يوما مما ساهم في تجنب
مجاعه كانت تهدد ملايين الناس حول العالم